gold or bitcoin where would you invest
your money i have my money in gold
okay so we already have that answer and
just give us your thoughts on
just everything that's going on with
bitcoin and crypto and blockchain are
you a believer is it part of your
portfolio
value digital gold if it's a store of
value then you're smoking crack
because any anything that can go from 58
000 to 48 000 is not
it's not a store of value it's a hell of
a rollercoaster ride
it's a lot of fun yeah i mean that's
what gogo investments are
but if bitcoin is going to be a store of
value it's going to have to become a
much less
volatile asset class looking for
stability here
well that's what a store value is okay
so forget about the store
but you know put on your crystal ball i
get it you're not uh
but it's it went in the last six months
from ten thousand
almost fifty thousand bucks i see it
which is
that's not normal no agreed but that's
what happens sure i guess when you start
printing a printing party at the pizza
party pizza pizza you know like it's
happening
well of course everybody wants to make
money easily nobody wants to work
for their money everybody just wants to
people don't want to
save money to invest they want to save
very little money and have the
investment explode
that's what they want to do they want
the easy way out so you you see some
people ending up with
severe egg on their face with the with
the bitcoin who bought at 58 000.
it's now at 48 000. right because
they've heard it's going to 400 000.
right but again i mean i go back to the
bigger picture i don't think china's
going to sit down
and let some digital currency become
the global reserve currency okay i think
china's got their eye on the price i
have this interview
one year from now right it's early
twenty
ask me where i think bitcoin's gonna be
it's in a bubble i mean okay
it could be a hundred thousand i mean it
really depends on
how much more liquidity the fed can pump
into the system without generating
enough inflation to kind of blow up this
debt bubble that we're sitting on
okay so if the fed can keep the party
going you know theoretically
and and people see bitcoin as kind of
fed defense
that's how they look at it because if
the guy if the fed's going to do this
i'm going to do that hedging against the
that's that's how it's viewed so last
point with bitcoin
you start to see these uh it's starting
to get
legitimacy you're starting to see tesla
and square
and you know jp morgan and certainly
open up a desk
and they're there the number that i've
seen is somewhere between
three and eight percent of their cash
reserves putting in the bitcoin
that's sort of the number i've seen not
jp morgan not jp okay square
square tesla and goldman sachs is
starting to look at it maybe goldman
sachs is opening up their desk
there's a lot of money to be made in
bitcoin okay so
i mean without a doubt and as we have
been discussing
china's not going to take over tomorrow
so as long as you still view the dollar
as being trashed by fiscal policy by
federal reserve policy
then and until china is a viable
alternative in china
as a medium of exchange the yuan is
growing
so that needs to be on people's radars
okay
but until china has that power if you
will
people are still going to look to
bitcoin as being the alternative to the
trashing of the dollar
what percentage of someone's portfolio
let's just talk asset allocation for a
second i guess it depends on your
age i mean you know maybe i mean you
need to look at the most
go-go corner of your portfolio
and call it five percent call it ten
percent whatever you want
just have if you wanna play that game
not 80
some people i know all they have is a
crypto account no 401k
no stock exposure no bonds but they're
all in on crypto
could get ugly for them yeah that's what
i'm saying
okay asset allocation we're learning
other things today
thank you for watching this short clip
if you want to see the full episode
check it out right here and if you have
not subscribed to valuetainment
click right here all we talk is money
all we talk is money